Với dốc nhìn vàc lý thì theo thái sợ thấp bể như ở Kim Cung Học và Kim Cung giá là gì?
Dùng cái tường Kim Cung thật với Kim Cung giá thì lòng chưa chí sạch là bởi vì thế nào?
Kim Cung ấy thì tải bây giờ nó tổn tải ngọi thì cho ngay là Kim Cung tự nhiên và Kim Cung nhìn tạo.
Kim Cung tự nhiên thành qua cả chiều năm rồi.
Và nó nằm xong ở những nằm cả chăng khi có mẹ.
Trong như cái điều kiện nó cũng cũng là giống mẹ.
Nó đạo là vì điều kiện của người như người nó và là vì như người thương nhiên.
Một loại thương ai là Kim Cung,
như tạo, Kim Cung biết tạo được tạo ra trong phòng thiện nghiệm trong điều kiện nghiệm,
lỗi rất giao và ám sất của rất giao.
Thực ra về kho học về bản chân,
thì Kim Cung tự nhiên và Kim Cung giết tạo là điều có khấu trúc dẫn nhận.
Đều trốn trúc, tự, các bạn,
tình dạy Kim Cung tụi khình dạng lập phương, là phương và nó tính chắc người như rống nhau.
Một cứng, người dì mà.
Chứ xuất đất nữa.
Chứ xuất đất để cho anh sáng lúc đi qua chậm.
Và nó phản sản quan hình như cái kia sáng chữ đến nó là mọi người cũng có mầu sạm.
Dạm đẹp.
Các tính chắc như rất như nhiệt.
Rất như tốt, nó như xú một lột lý khác rồi,
tính chắc với kho học thì không phát nhạm.
Nhưng mà yên xin khăn nhau hình đầy,
người làm ngùi dữ nốc của Việt Kim Cung.
Mìa, weo,
nhưng mà khi người đang ngùa phương Kim Cung ấy,
mình nói nó ngùi đốc này nó ngùi nước,
Kim Cung tự nhiên.
Thì nó khăn nhớm nó trị.
Thì nó khăn nhớm nó tụi khả.
Con mình nói nó để để tìm cường như bảo.
Thì nó này khác.
Chứ còn về kho học nó không có khi ngừng khảm bật khi gương dạng.
Mình nó có chút lống nhau, bình chất lống nhau.
Ờ,
nhưng mà nó khác nhau được khác nhau về giá trịnh như bây giờ.
Thần Việt như là.
Em là?
Thì gương thầy đầy đầy dạy dạy dạy dạy.